[Música]
el presidente de brasil jair bolsonaro
confirmó que sufre una obstrucción
intestinal por lo que fue hospitalizado
esta madrugada al mandatario se le están
realizando exámenes para establecer si
requiere o no cirugía tenemos
información desde el río de janeiro
a partir de hoy cambian las
restricciones en francia para contener a
la variante omicron del hobby 19 más
teletrabajo los niños deberán portar
mascarillas y el aforo en lugares de
ocio queda limitado mientras la asamblea
francesa disfrutes y el pase sanitario
se convierte en fase de vacunación
se cumplen dos años desde que el general
iraní qasem soleimani murió en medio de
un ataque estadounidense el presidente
de la república islámica prometió
venganza a menos que el exmandatario
donald trump que estaba al frente de la
casa blanca en el momento de los hechos
sea juzgado ampliamos en esta emisión
a ustedes gracias por continuar con
nosotros en france 24 soy valentina
torre sánchez y es un gusto acompañarlos
iniciamos este informativo en brasil
donde el presidente ya árbol sonar fue
hospitalizado en sao paulo y confirmó
que sufre de una obstrucción intestinal
a través de su cuenta de twitter el
mandatario indicó que empezó a sentirse
mal el domingo por lo que llegó al
hospital vilanova estar esta madrugada
actualmente está usando una sonda
nasogástrica y le realizarán más
exámenes para determinar si requiere una
cirugía el jefe de estado señaló también
que esta su segunda hospitalización con
los mismos síntomas y que es una
consecuencia del apuñalamiento que
sufrió en 2018 cuando se encontraba en
campaña a la presidencia desde entonces
se le han realizado cuatro cirugías
vamos al río de janeiro con nuestro
corresponsal y agilidad off quien más
temprano nos envió el siguiente reporte
el presidente brasileño tenía que
aprovechar un día más de vacaciones con
su esposa y su hija en la costa del
estado sureño de santa catarina pero ha
tenido que viajar durante la madrugada
sea san pablo el siente dolor abdominal
desde algunos días su médico antonio
luis macedo también ha tenido que
interrumpir sus vacaciones en las islas
bahamas él informó que revolucionaron
será sometido a exámenes para ver si se
trata de una nueva oclusión intestinal
en julio del año pasado llegué bolsonaro
ya había sido internado durante cinco
días en el mismo hospital vilanova a
estar por el mismo problema de bloqueo
intestinal esta fragilidad es una
consecuencia del ataque que sufrió
durante la campaña electoral de 2018
cuando fue apuñalado en el abdomen según
el primer boletín médico que acaba de
ser publicado el cuadro del presidente
brasileño es estable pero no hay ninguna
previsión para su salida del hospital en
francia el gobierno de manuel marco no
presenta a la asamblea nacional el
proyecto que convertiría el conocido
pase sanitario en un pase vacunal es
decir que sólo las personas la pauta
completa de inoculación tendrían acceso
a restaurantes eventos y transporte
público entre otros
entretanto a partir de hoy hay nuevas
medidas para hacer frente al repunte de
casos de kobe 19 que ha generado la
variante omicron más en el siguiente
informe
cogen jolie no tenía previsto pasar su
domingo sola en su oficina a partir de
este lunes su empresa como todas las
otras tendrá que acelerar el ritmo del
teletrabajo de tres a cuatro días por
semana como mínimo para limitar el auge
de contagios algo que obliga a esta
directora ejecutiva a planificar el
regreso de vacaciones
y nosotros esperamos a que haya un 10
por ciento de efectivos contagiados al
mismo tiempo el reto es evitar que
contagien a todos nuestros empleados de
lo contrario tendríamos un riesgo por
ello hemos aplicado mucho el teletrabajo
como todas las empresas
también se busca limitar los contagios
en las escuelas con nuevas reglas para
hacer frente al contacto con un caso
positivo se autoriza el ingreso a las
aulas después de haber obtenido un
resultado negativo en una prueba pcr de
antígenos pero habrá que someterse de
nuevo a un test dos días después y luego
cuatro días después un control
suplementario que podrá ser realizado
por los padres en casa
serás es una situación que es así nos
tenemos que adaptar que no estoy muy a
favor de que los niños estén vacunados
por lo tanto mientras les podamos hacer
pruebas y proceder de esa manera está
bien a shannon browm la mascarilla pasa
a ser obligatoria para los niños mayores
de 6 años algo que ya estaba en vigor
para los adultos llevarlo en la nariz
así como el transporte público
consecuencia prohibido comer a bordo el
gobierno habría preferido aprobar esta
medida el pasado fin de semana de gran
tráfico para aplicar una norma que aún
genera dudas
muy feas y yo viajo nueve horas por eso
prefería hacerlo hoy domingo
nueva norma para las salas de
espectáculos el aforo se limite a dos
mil espectadores solamente este circo
aparecido con capacidad para 14 mil 600
personas había vendido todo para los
próximos días y ahora debe repartir a
esos espectadores que hemos añadido
funciones y hemos multiplicado al
público a través de las redes sociales y
la gente se inscribió para las nuevas
funciones al final esto termino sin
mayor dificultad de pases o para los
deportes y los espectáculos al aire
libre el aforo se reduce a cinco mil
personas
y es que poco más de un mes después de
ser reportada por primera vez los
expertos tienen más información sobre la
variante omicron los recortes de
contagios a nivel mundial confirman las
primeras hipótesis de su alta
transmisibilidad y ahora los expertos
tienen más pistas sobre su gravedad y el
efecto que podría tener durante 2022
manuel acá no nos explica por qué se con
que se conoce con certeza de este linaje
hasta el momento
la más contagiosa de la historia la
velocidad de transmisión de la variante
omicron ha sorprendido a los expertos
con sus más de 30 mutaciones ha sido en
parte la causante de que el mundo
registrará récords de casos de kobe 19 a
nivel mundial tras algo más de un mes de
ser reportada los expertos tienen un
poco más de claridad sobre la gravedad
de la variante que podría ser más leve
al atacar de manera menos pronunciada a
los pulmones y los datos de la
universidad de oxford muestran que a
pesar del aumento pronunciado de los
casos las muertes a nivel global
disminuyen un comportamiento diferente
al de otras olas la respuesta compartida
entre múltiples expertos es el efecto de
la vacunación definitivamente lo que sí
sabemos las personas que no se han
vacunado cuando se contagian de la
variante o mika tienen más riesgo
especializarse y también de complicarse
el gran problema es la sobrecarga en el
sistema de salud debido a su alta
transmisibilidad muchas más personas
necesitarán atención médica
tenemos que tener cuidado con eso porque
incluso si tienes un porcentaje de menor
gravedad cuando tienes múltiples
múltiples personas infectadas con esa
cantidad neta todavía habrá muchas
personas que necesitarán hospitalización
y esa es la razón por la que estamos
preocupados por estresar o sobrecargar
el sistema hospitalario
cada vez más se presenta la palabra
endemia para referirse a la evolución
del coi 19 una palabra que hace
referencia a un proceso patológico que
se mantiene de forma estacionaria en una
población por ahora es sólo una
hipótesis que la pandemia no
desaparecerá sino que tendremos que
convivir con el virus que ha marcado los
dos últimos años en irán el presidente
de brain rice y prometió venganza por el
fallecimiento del general qasem
soleimani cuando se cumplen dos años de
su muerte en medio de un operativo
estadounidense el mandatario aseguró que
las retaliaciones por la muerte de
sulejmani sólo se detendrán si el
expresidente de donald trump que estuvo
al frente de la casa blanca al momento
del operativo es juzgado conectamos con
catalina gómez ángel corresponsal de
france 24 en teherán que se encuentra en
roma por las festividades catalina que
representaba qasem soleimani para irán y
como ocurrió el operativo que terminó
con su muerte
bueno muy buenos días para ustedes
cassen suleman era el general más
importante que tenía no solamente los
guardianes revolucionarios sino toda la
institución militar de irán y casi en
oriente medio' era un experto en guerra
de guerrillas era un experto en
contrainsurgencia y tuvo un papel muy
importante en muchísimos desde la guerra
con irak en la década de los 80 pero
especialmente también durante el ascenso
de isis especialmente en irak él jugó un
papel muy importante en reorganizar esas
fuerzas iraquíes que habían quedado
básicamente destruidas en el momento que
crisis entra en el país pero también
jugaba un papel simbólico en irán- era
como la gran figura después del líder
supremo representaba ese movimiento que
para la revolución islámica es tan
importante que es la resistencia contra
lo que ellos llaman el estado sionista e
israel y adicionalmente tenía un gran
relación con todos estos líderes pro
iraníes en la región hasán nasralá en el
líbano con nosotros líderes en ir a por
eso su pérdida puede muy dolorosa para
iraní y ha tenido también un gran
impacto en toda la región porque
representaba ese símbolo hay bastantes
opiniones encontradas sobre si fue
efectivo para eeuu haberlo asesinado
muchos piensan que vino en su contra
debido a que es mucho más difícil para
iran organizar y tener el control y la
coordinación con esos grupos que son
aliados en la región
catalina muchas gracias por esta
ampliación y por compartirla con
nosotros en france 24 y finalizamos en
hong kong donde el popular portal de
noticias citizen news cerró sus puertas
y condenó lo que calificó de la caída en
picada de las libertades de la prensa
los periodistas indicaron que ya no se
sienten seguros para publicar después de
que sus colegas del medio star news
fueran arrestados por supuesta sedición
shyris en news contaba con más de 800
mil suscriptores en sus redes sociales
llegamos al final de este informativo
ustedes gracias por su sintonía feliz
día
[Música]